here yes okay so check this out
want to see a [ __ ] hero among men
so this guy this is in australia
this guy got pulled over for drinking
from an open container
check it when it comes to finding
impaired drivers
this is like their version of cops or
whatever up in newcastle
one moment's hesitation puts this driver
under the spotlight
bring him in just push him down the end
just pulled up sure but with multiple
units on standby
there's nowhere to run everything driver
yeah my name's andrew gilmore newcastle
highway patrol have you had anything to
drink this evening
how many drinks have you had today sir
i had two bourbon and cokes at shaw bay
country club around
five o'clock okay got pulled over do you
weighed
is that all no i've had a few more since
then have you i've got a long neck here
with me
and you've been drinking in the car have
you you understand that's an offence
offensive he was drinking
in the car finally i'm over isn't it
hey you could give hey guys we're legit
now you could give us the gems
whatsoever
on the trouble so where's the long neck
how much of that there it is there it is
it's nearly half gone
that's from hannah damien bought a long
neck mixer of bourbon and cola
to keep him company on the three-hour
drive to sydney so you're drinking
woodstock birmingham whilst you're
driving
nice beast do it dog
and that's just topping up on what he
had at the club
when was your last sip oh [ __ ] probably
about 15 minutes ago
yeah probably about 15 minutes again
you've consumed apart from the two at
shoal bay
all right having already admitted to
drinking whilst driving breathalyzer
damien
breathalyzer straight on the tube all
right all right so let's
let's take some bets here [ __ ] i love
australia
breathalyzer what do you think he blows
in the breathalyzer
i want to know let's take a guess here
what do you think he blows on the
breathalyzer
.09 somebody's saying in the drobo chat
uh 69 nice .12
uh 0.2 in the trovo chat and uh 4
20 69 nice .17
i see youtube chat 0.08
3.4 0.25 uh 0.13
0.21 6.9 nice
uh d live .14 uh 0.18
so let's check it out let's find out
put your lips right around and blow
no no no no not hard nice and steady
right just pretend you're blowing up a
balloon but just nice and steady you
don't have to blow the actual
the back side out of it okay and lips
around blow
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going
thank you that's fine officer gilmore's
gut instinct is that damian
will blow over and the result shocks
everyone
oh wow he might be there trying to make
a u-turn to turn around and head the
other way
i really had nowhere to go in the end oh
boy damian's moment of indecision
may have been down to the bourbon he was
necking on his 200k
trip back to sydney and lips around blow
keep going keep going keep going keep
going what did he blow where did he blow
damian's long journey home could now
come to a screeching halt
oh
[ __ ] victory yes yes
point zero zero
zero
point zero zero
zero
[Music]
[Applause]
get him get him damien get him
[Applause]
[Music]
yes yes
[Music]
[ __ ] yes the winner
look at that look at that
now that's a man that is a [ __ ]
man but maybe not how can that be
that's what i don't understand but
definitely showing up zero
regardless of the zero results officer
gilmore is
not impressed at that point you got to
let him off
i mean look i understand he was drinking
i get it but out of principle's sake you
got to go look
i'm letting you off guess what today's
your lucky night
you're off how would you drink and drive
i'm going to sydney so i just thought
but why would you drink alcohol whilst
you're driving say whatever you want
zero zero zero
that's all you need to know it's not
going to intoxicate me
how do you know any bit of alcohol
especially that
what's not going to intoxicate them how
do you know because the breathalyzer
came up with
zero zero
zero amount of alcohol is going to have
some effect
have you got a drinking problem uh no
obviously not
because and say it with me
zero zero
zero no i dropped my daughter around a
bay and the bottle shop was there i
thought
oh i just have a bourbon on my way to
sydney
suspicious the breathalyzer might be
faulty officer gilmore isn't taking
any chances i have to apologize but i'm
going to have to re-test you i believe
that the
machine that i've got there might be
something wrong with it okay
i like the first reading well i can
understand that
what i need to do lips around and blow
nice and steady go ahead now blow
keep going keep going keep going stop
now thank you this second test
should set the record straight finally
this will fix it
yes he did it again
he did it again he did it twice
you thought it was faulty it wasn't
it wasn't he did it again
[Applause]
he did it again new machine at all
twice twice
[ __ ] you and your machine
it was a new machine
[Music]
what a hero what a [ __ ]
hero get him
get him yes
two machines two
he said [ __ ] your machine
[ __ ] your machine suck my dick
can you just hop out of the car for me
please what are you gonna get him for
being too awesome what are you gonna
arrest them for
being the [ __ ] man
let them off dude what machine i get in
my pj
two you let this guy off you let this go
off and you give him whatever money you
have in your wallet
that's the rule if you do what this man
did
if you do what this hero did you give
him whatever's in your wallet
and you let him go and you let him go
give him your gun to give him your gun
give him what's in your wallet
he gets to be a cop for the night
because of this
i just want you to help out damian says
he's had a drink
there's an open bottle of bourbon on the
seat and he's still blue zero
so could the drinking story be a red
herring
to mask something else have you had any
other substance this evening
nope nothing at all it's just i'm
looking at your eyes and they just
don't look right to me i'm fine
i just drove from sydney to newcastle
i spent two hours with my daughter now i
gotta drive home
um maybe intestine for whatever
it's fine you have any illicit
substances whatsoever
no mate i've got to drive back no that's
not the issue i'm saying a lot of people
they're tired take listen substances so
now they're trying to get him for
something else look at that it wasn't
enough that he's a hero
it wasn't enough that he was an american
hero that wasn't enough
that wasn't enough to make sure that
they can drive further
and further and further
[Music]
but officer gilmore is not i don't want
to put another person on the road that
might be affected by
some illicit drug and then put you know
our families in
in jeopardy shut up shut up [ __ ] you
illicit substances whatsoever
no mate i gotta drive back home yeah
that's not the uh
just saw it over here kim just walk up
here
you do me a favor just walk right across
to those offices
in a straight line and then turn around
and come back for me thank you
in the absence of a drug testing kit
police put damien through his paces
he's doing it the old-fashioned way he's
doing it all right
just take your finger and point close
your eyes and try and put the end of
your nose
all right you see him okay i'm fine yeah
all right
infringement for that and then you were
on your way but how much is the
infringement
uh 300 you're in fridge for that but
then you're on your way
did he get let off that's that's just
silly
did he get let off did he win well we
drink
we can't drink it did he win in a
position where
an infringement for that and then you
get let off did this man win
i'd like you to dispose it because i'm
not going to let you drive with that in
the car
again and then take the bubble with you
thank you very much
all right massive lesson i think it
should be an expensive lesson mate you
put yourself at risk and opposite risk
by doing that okay
nice to meet you andrea
oh my [ __ ]
god holy [ __ ]
the hero the [ __ ]
[Music]
hero
dude they had him do the walking thing
the finger thing
two [ __ ] dicks the [ __ ] man
the man
[Applause]
yes
this guy this guy's a [ __ ] hero
you're right he made those cops look
like
goddamn clowns
wow this is [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
man
the [ __ ] yeah exactly not since the
sky king have we seen such a display
the road king will live forever
this guy is [ __ ] amazing
yes suck a dick
suck it in coppers
wow wow 300 bucks
okay fine better than going to jail i
pay that 300
bucks standing on my head you're [ __ ]
done you win
you win
this guy is [ __ ]
awesome
the real god damn
road warrior
[ __ ] yeah get it
oh [ __ ]
guy i i mean i know i shouldn't be this
excited but for whatever reason
for whatever reason
this is for you australia you never get
enough love on this
show
[Music]
there he is that's the shot that's the
shot right there there it is
[Music]
suck a dick crocodile dundee we have a
new australian hero
[Music]
you should feel very proud of this man
if you're from australia
very very proud you very proud
not since mel gibson has a man come from
australia
and stolen our hearts like him
[Music]
steve irwin good thing you died because
this man would have killed you with
shame
shame
[Music]
the hero
he blew way down under jeff very good
way down under
way down under
are you guys as happy as i am about this
i'm [ __ ] very happy
[Music]
all right all right you know
god damn that was [ __ ] great
holy [ __ ]